[Música]
ante un Palau Sant Jordi repleto y
acompañado del afecto de su público Joan
Manuel Serrat se despidió de los
escenarios Gracias a todos ustedes
Gracias a todos ustedes gracias a todos
por acompañarme hoy como lo han hecho
y especial y especialmente esta noche en
la que solemnemente proclamó mi
despedida por voluntad propia
comida también por voluntad propia
vine a despedirme pero vine a despedirme
con alegría lo hizo en su Barcelona
natal con un repertorio reflejo de su
época pero también de los cambios que ha
vivido el mundo desde su arranque A
mediados de los años 60 cuando su voz
chocaba contra la represión franquista a
quienes ventor de varias generaciones en
España y América Latina le pudo a
instantes la emoción pero pidió a un
público también conmovido que disfrutará
de la noche damas caballeros
damas caballeros etcétera etcétera dejen
de lado cualquier tentación que puedan
tener de nostalgia o melancolía que los
pueda amenazar esto es una fiesta
aparte de los 15.000 espectadores en el
Palau Sant Jordi en las últimas horas
las redes sociales le han colmado de
gratitud el compositor ha recibido el
saludo de cientos de admiradores
artistas y políticos entre los cuales
destaca el presidente del gobierno Pedro
Sánchez y la alcaldesa de Barcelona Ada
colau Serrat no volverá a ofrecer
conciertos pero mediterráneo tu nombre
me sabe a hierba temera tems no hago
otra cosa que pensar en ti o cantar es
con los famosos versos de Machado
Caminante no hay camino quedan como un
legado imborrable del nueve
[Música]